update on the
uh9
1589 yeah veterans treatment
Court
thanks
representa
Maguire good to you this one has my
name uh let's take a
minute
the only change from yesterday is the
appropriation it's 163,000 now it was
100,00 th000
yesterday that's to account for the
coordinator position for half a
year
e
okay you may recall yesterday we did
vote on this
and I think of the motion was made by
representative
grassie just want to make sure
everything is as we
recall so Mike you put in the the two
little changes that representative Leon
wanted is that yeah
yeah could you point us in that
direction not put page in
line one thing we fail to get yes this
one 21 L
23 it's the position yeah
269,000 we failed to get yesterday
represent guire you had asked for a
breakdown of group two employees from
liquor and I don't think we received
that and skip that oh in the
bill yeah you had asked I my notes that
you they have a list of 10 or so people
and that was in the other bill I don't
know if it's in
this we
toel all the models in here franchising
agent
so on so forth who makes the
decision on on page five just a
definition so which one are we is this
bill say is going to be the
law so this bill is the agency model uh
but it defines all other possible models
but it is the agency this is the Run by
St the agency
not run by state liquor
but regulated by state liquor owned
privately
correct the lay
model no what some members of the senate
senate hasn't taken a position yet
allegedly because I've spoken to members
of the Senate and they have no they said
send over what you've got and we'll take
a look at it they haven't taken a
position on it yet from my
understanding
that's
interesting
uh representative Maguire would like a
show of hands if possible that what we
see in front of us is what we believe
we've acted on
yesterday yeah yeah okay you don't
[Laughter]
agree
e
let's go to so we do have an issue
apparently with the county language
apologies Mr chairman Kate hen from the
New Hampshire Association of counties so
page six 318 uh line
34 to page seven through line eight it
references the court doing electronic
monitoring and developing criteria to
evaluate but uh and that the court shall
order the person to reimburse the court
for payment of the cost of electronic
monitoring I think in those whole
sections you want it to say County and
not Court um because quite frankly the
court is not going to have anything to
do with the electronic monitoring
program so you probably want the
counties developing the criteria and the
counties getting reimbursed rather than
the court represent mire thank you so on
the bottom of page six I think let's
start let's go line by line yeah the
court shall order electronic monitoring
that makes sense
right yep that's fine okay the court
shall develop a criteria to determine
whether the person is Indigent or not
that that way we'll have a consistent
criteria um across the whole state which
I would think makes sense right yeah I I
would argue that each County program
looks very different and counties are
very different so being Indigent in one
County may not be Indigent in another
County and if you allow the courts to
use the standard that they use to
determine whether or not you are
Indigent for the purposes of getting an
attorney doesn't necessarily mean that
you are Indigent for purposes of paying
for electronic monitoring those are two
very different
standards okay what is what are others
think I mean I could go with that
but just reading
this so re refresh our memories how did
this come out
originally from Criminal Justice it's
all court stuff it's it came out all
court stuff and but we moved it to the
you moved it all to the counties
yesterday but this piece is still with
the courts because Miss krian told us
the court doesn't have any pre-trial um
Division and therefore they can't do
this right
so
Mr Hof
see why wouldn't um on line five page
seven changing Court to
County why wouldn't that accomplish it
because doesn't the court isn't the
court the one who determines who's on
electric monitoring and who's not so it
is my understanding and aerin's not here
but it is my understanding that the
court suggests electronic monitor in but
it does not
force a county to use electronic
monitoring right now because statutorily
they are not required to have electronic
monitoring and not every county has
electronic monitoring this changes
that but I
think I would the counties would be
extremely concerned if the courts are in
charge of determining incy and it's not
something that they can control for
their program because straford
program and payments look very different
from Marx's payments and programs which
looks very different from chesher which
looks very different from
Rockingham so like marac is like $7 a
day to be
out straford is $100 a
week yeah but they straford offers
opportunity for you to volunteer to work
that off so that you don't have to so I
guess I'm just arguing for the more
flexibility the better if you are going
to require counties to do
this yeah I'm I I'm accept that's
acceptable to me I mean I I think um
this is a new
thing um let's let different counties do
what they want to do if one of them
turns out to be the most Superior way
and and the others are not then we could
later say okay everybody do it that way
right but but if we if we make a
decision here it has to be this way or
whatever then we precluded finding
different choices so I'm I'm happy with
that I don't know all of the details on
everyone's electronic monitoring so I
wouldn't want I only know maramax and
Stafford's numbers so I can't give
the details on rocking hams or Chesters
off the top of my head but I could try
and find out before 11:30 if that would
be
helpful it's it's roughly a factor of
two I think so it's it can be
significant yeah I was just looking back
through the comparisons of the trying to
find where this all started and
changed
I think In the comparison it was it was
courts and then uh I think
representative Maguire had an amendment
to make it the
counties and uh I kind of the division
went away from that and then went back
to it went back to the courts to the
counties but didn't get it into
here so
fight so Mr Hoffman what would be the
easy fix for you I just wanted to go
through what I think of the changes
before I go run it off perfect yeah uh
bottom of page
six line 34 we would change to the
county shall develop uniform
criteria top of page
seven line five the courtial order that
the person reimburse the
county and then on line nine same page
County finds the person is Indigent for
the purpose of
repaying instead of court so those three
changes so line nine on page nine seven
page
seven
so the clerk points out again line three
on page seven where it
says so we
have and and line five on page
seven
14 yes question so three yep if we
change it to the court shall develop
uniform criteria is that where you went
the flexibility I think you you want
line three page seven yes so if the
county finds that the person is not
Indigent yeah also line 15 on page seven
yeah but not
line uh
right because conditions are imposed by
the court yeah right right so okay all
right and then over here we
have okay so we have on page six line 34
line
36 and on page seven line
35 9 and
15 that look good with you Mr Hoffman
yes I'll have a changed in both
amendments the one with five and the one
with 10 okay thanks thank thank you
y all
right yes
yeah so there they have many eyes on
something absolutely there's a really
good reason why this whole process is so
slow and has so many steps and has the
third reading motion and has all that
sort of stuff it's for exactly things
like this that you know you want it to
be right at the end of the
day I see
on yeah yes we had a vote on
that all right we'll see you at
11:30
e
for